a veteran worker of the scp foundation
sits at his terminal
performing one of the most critical
tasks in the entire organization
creating a file for an as yet
undescribed scp
but there's something terribly wrong his
eyes are glazed over
his mouth hangs open is this a zombie
or a train foundation researcher what is
going on
like any large international
organization it takes more than just the
exciting action-filled jobs to keep the
wheels turning at the scp
foundation sure the head researchers
guards mobile task force soldiers and
members of the o5 command get all the
praise
but a legion of number crunchers
cleaners and paper pushers are equally
important
one such person was archivist walter
bainbridge
who had been tasked with digitizing some
of the older records that the foundation
had on file
it was when he was innocently recording
the details on scp-050-0
that he first came under the strange and
startling effects
of scp-055 but the most peculiar part
as with all incidents of scp-055's
anomalous effects taking
hold is that walter had no idea any of
it was happening
in his new digitized filing system he
first took note of scp-053
euclid class also known as the young
girl
this anomaly was a seemingly normal
human female child who provoked
homicidal insanity
in those directly exposed to her then
scp-054
safe class a non-aggressive humanoid
female made entirely of
as well as biologically and chemically
identical to regular spring water
next scp-056 euclid class
a being that changes form to suit its
environment but only when all observers
lose focus
of it and then scp-057
safe class an underground chamber that
crushes the humans who walk within
it was at this point that walter
received a concerned message from one of
his superiors at site 19
mr kovach the message praised the
thorough digitization of the other
anomalies records
but was confused about why walter had
left out any mention of scp-055
immediately walter was embarrassed how
could he have forgotten scp-055
that iconic anomaly known for well he
couldn't quite say
off the top of his head but he'd be sure
to look into it
a quick trip to the site 19 archive
showed him that there was actually quite
a hefty file on the nature of scp-055
which must have been the result of a
huge number of studies
what struck him as strange was that all
the files were filled out in pen
rather than being typed up like a
traditional file the majority of these
nodes were written in shorthand too
as though they were frantically taken
during the tests themselves on extremely
short notice
there weren't even any redactions walter
made a mental note of what he had seen
put the file back in its proper place
and headed back to his computer terminal
however after riding in an almost
trance-like state
he looked back on his work to see that
he had written an entry on scp-058
a giant evil bovine heart with insect
legs and a scorpion stinger
strange he thought that's when walter
got a call from mr kovach on his
foundation issue phone
and he didn't sound happy he'd given
walter direct
instructions to go back and digitize the
files on zero five five
and instead he'd been working on zero
five eight what was the meaning of this
walter was typically an extremely loyal
and diligent employee
but the verbal barrage from his
supervisor had him considering talking
back
just this once and hoping it didn't get
him demoted to d-class
and thrown into 682's acid bath for
playtime
walter gold picked up some courage and
interrupted mr kovach's rant to ask if
he had any idea what scp-055
actually was the line went silent for a
moment
then his supervisor spoke again this
time
with less confidence of course i can
tell you about scp-055
it's a classic one of the first hundred
how could you forget it's
uh or yeah you know it's
i think it's the one with um
another long pause as mr kovach seemed
to search for the words
but instead just trailed off into
silence
knowing that some of the anomalies on
file were dangerous memetic hazards
walter was worried for a moment that he
may have accidentally killed his boss by
getting him to think too hard about
scp-055
he asked if mr kovach was okay and
finally got a reply
i'm sorry i seem to have zoned out for a
second there what were we talking about
again
but this time it was walter who couldn't
answer
he had no idea at all what the two of
them were discussing just moments ago
he felt disoriented and kind of sick
like they'd taken some low level of knee
sticks
mr kovach told walter to get back to his
filing duties and they'd speak later
walter then checked the messages he'd
received from mr kovach earlier
and there it was plain as day you missed
zero five five
go back and digitize that before
proceeding mr k
but walter had never even heard of an
scp-055 if such an anomaly even existed
what was going on here in that moment
walter realized he was dealing with
something much stranger than just a
standard digitization job
after all how could he properly complete
his duties if scp-055
seemed to be impossible to speak write
or even think about
unless you were directly observing it at
that moment
walter had to know and ask around the
entirety of site 19
to find the answers if he had to sadly
for walter
he was about to embark on a much more
challenging task than he could have ever
imagined
to paraphrase a supposed quote from
socrates all i know is that
i know nothing and that's also about the
extent of the knowledge we have on
scp-055
also known as the anti-meme and the
self-keeping secret
what does it look like when and how was
it obtained by the foundation
what are its anomalous abilities is this
thing dangerous
we may never know because the only
anomalous ability of scp-055 that we're
aware of
is the fact that nobody is capable of
retaining any information
about it it's crucial to note that
whatever zero five five
is it isn't invisible or indescribable
foundation personnel are perfectly
capable of entering its containment
chamber
and observing it without incident but
mere minutes after leaving the chamber
any memories of the particulars of zero
five five seem to spontaneously erase
themselves
hence the self-keeping secret but this
didn't deter walter
perhaps his greatest advantage was that
he didn't know enough about the thing he
was investigating to know how futile his
mission was
he wanted to know the unknowable and a
pesky issue like
impossibility wouldn't stop him he'd get
to whoever he needed to at site 19 to
get the answers he
needed of course most people had no
knowledge of the mysterious anomaly
the common response he got back from his
colleagues was zero five five
do we even have a zero five five well
the realization of sudden memory loss
or the realization of zero five five's
existence has been known to cause
momentary stress
there are no known long-term physical or
mental effects from zero five five's
anomalous abilities
it's a fleeting idea in its purest form
like forgetting why you walked into a
room zero five five could be the most
harmless object on the foundation's
roster
or the most deadly either way
we just don't know at times walter
worried he was going insane
zero five five and everything related to
it was gaslighting him
was zero five five even real the one
thing that proved to him that zero five
five must have existed
is that its containment chamber existed
according to the official records kept
by the foundation on the site 19
containment facilities
0.5 is kept in a 5x5 by 2.5 meter square
room
constructed of 50-foot thick cement with
a faraday cage surrounding the cement
walls
the report continues that access is via
a heavy containment door measuring two
by 2.5 meters
constructed on bearings to ensure door
closes and locks automatically unless
held open deliberately
zero five five cell is one of the few to
have no posted security guards
and any personnel working on other scps
in the area
are ordered to remain at least 50 feet
from the geometric center of zero five
five cell where the anomaly itself is
kept
when he tried to explore further why the
cell was constructed in this manner
he found that surprise surprise nobody
knew zero five five was an anomaly whose
containment requirements were so
mysterious that it automatically netted
itself a ketter class designation
after all how can you properly contain
something you can't even hope to
comprehend
there were plenty of rumors about the
true nature of zero five five
some of the more conspiratorial minds at
site 19 theorized that zero five five
was actually an
autonomous or remotely controlled spy
inserted into the site to observe
foundation
operations or even humanity as a whole
if you're on the more paranoid end of
the psychological spectrum
this theory makes total sense an anomaly
that's physically impossible to remember
even when writings and pictures on the
subject exist would be a perfect spy
however this was all ultimately little
more than speculation
walter was barely any further along than
when he started
there were multiple points in his
investigations where walter seriously
considered giving up
until finally he had a major
breakthrough
dr bartholomew hughes and dr john
marachek were two
scientists that had performed extensive
research into zero five five
and who walter hoped might have the
answers he sought about the self-keeping
secret
these scientists were the first to
discover the anti-mimetic nature of zero
five five
performing numerous tests on d-class
personnel to see if it was possible to
create
feasible written records sketches or any
other records or impressions that could
bypass
its anomalous effects the disorienting
memory ruining effects of zero five five
also extend to any materials concerning
zero five five it seems to be a truly
uncrackable code
but dr hughes may have finally found
some cracks in the armor
for starters the fact that we're able to
remember that zero five five is an
anti-mimetic is an ironic exception to
its anti-memetic qualities
this revelation also inspired another
realization from dr hughes
would it be possible to discover more
about zero five five from the process of
deduction
rather than the typical induction in
other words
could they possibly learn about zero
five five by figuring out all the things
it isn't
rather than what it is dr marachek
designed an experiment with dr hughes to
explore this theory
they designed the experiment around a
simple question is zero
five five not spherical in designing the
question to specifically find out what
zero five
five isn't they hoped to subvert the
anomaly's anti-mimetic powers
walter was fascinated by this potential
method of getting answers
marachek and hughes found that while the
questioning process for those exposed
was often arduous and frustrating
they could now definitely say that zero
five five
is not a sphere it is theoretically
possible to discover the true nature of
zero five five by an almost endless
barrage of deductive questions
though whether command would authorize
the resources for such extensive testing
is still an open question walter in his
desperation
begged marachek and hughes for clearance
to vue 055
himself the curiosity had become too
great during a search to just walk away
with the single fact that zero five five
wasn't spherical he needed to seed this
thing
and after several weeks of filling out
forms and cutting red tape
his wish was finally granted walter
bainbridge was allowed a private
audience with scp-055 the subject
of his months-long obsession outsiders
observed that walters spent
just over an hour in the containment
chamber taking photos
drawing sketches writing down notes
recording audio logs
and reciting memory mnemonics he was
pulling out every stop to counteract the
anti-memetic effects of the self-keeping
secret
he was adamant that he would not be
defeated by his non-spherical nemesis
not after all this time and effort once
his time
in the zero five five containment
chamber was over he retired back to his
office to finally digitize his
exhaustive findings
so that his supervisor mr kovach would
finally get off his back
walter smiled took a deep breath and
began to type
scp-059 keter class
this anomaly is a radioactive mineral
that emits a unique radiation known as
delta radiation
exposure to this radiation has caused
strange fungal growths on the infected
wait what was this supposed to be about
again oh well it couldn't have been that
important
anyway check out scp-096 the shy guy
and scp-3008 trapped in ikea
for more unforgettable tales from the
scp foundation